Have you been following Dr. McCullough's new articles about talent doing too much keto or
fasting damage or metabolism because of stress via cortisol? It's like he's done a 180-degree
turtle as a vice. He said it's better for me to try to get energy from glucose.
Well, you know, you do have to be careful with, you know, anybody will follow it. Dr.
McCullough, I love him, you know, dearly. He's a great guy, but he jumps on his bandwagon
all the time. And you do it to be careful that, you know, he really pushes different things
really hard to sell things, which I don't like that about him. But I do agree with this point.
So, when he was on the giant bandwagon doing keto and fasting all the time for people who are
not cancer patients, I don't like those bandwagens because, you know, these aren't good for everybody.
And I don't think these diets are good for everybody. And you see books written on them that everybody
should do keto. You know, this is the danger of Instagram and Facebook because somebody who
is doing something, let's say they're doing a keto diet, then they think that everybody should do
a keto diet. Not everybody's metabolism is set up to do a keto diet. They can't do a keto diet.
It wouldn't be healthy for them. Just like somebody who goes, who goes to vegan,
thinks everybody should go vegan. The truth is vegan can be a healthy thing for people.
And vegan can be the least healthy thing for probably most people.
So, now the biggest craves is this carnivore diet. Everybody should only be eating meat.
Okay, whenever you have that word only in there, you should already show a red flag up in your
mind. So, I always go back. Okay, what's the thing that you kind of kind of put things in perspective
is God did put us in a garden. We are supposed to be eating vegetables. But then after the fall, he
did give us meat to eat. And he did give us grains to eat. And he did say that we're supposed to eat
seeds and nuts and things. So, to just cross these things off our list because of some diet that's
going around that some reputable doctor is pushing. I think it's wrong. You go back to
biblical ways of how we're supposed to eat. Now granted, our food has been adulterated. And granted,
our grains have been so scorched and damaged. It's crazy. And granted, a lot of people have gluten
sensitivities and they have antibodies to be added and we have peptides and dairy and different
dairy peptides and things. So, you do have to address those things because man is so destroyed
our food supply. But God has allowed us to eat everything. And, you know, we have to be in balance
with all that we eat. Now, everything might not be good for everybody. But it doesn't mean that it's not
something that, you know, is a bad thing to be doing. So, even a cancer, is it okay for a cancer
patient to be doing keto or fasting? Well, you know, when I've said about fast eating and I know there's
been there's disagreement out there about how long a person should fast if they have cancer. And I've
said that you probably shouldn't be doing too many fasts over 24 hours if you have cancer. And how long
should you be on a keto diet if you have cancer? If you have a cancer that would be beneficial for a
keto diet, which is typically like the brain cancers, it's not something you stay on the rest of your
life either. So, it's about that balance. And, you know, I have a long said to you that, you know,
we think about how food, how we grow food and, you know, should we be eating more in season? Should we
should we be eating apples every day? Just because apples aren't good for us. Maybe not. You know,
so, you know, we rotate our diet and rotate what we can eat.